I think the economy in 2009 will not
recover as long as each government takes
its own steps you like myself and others
it is important to have a dialogue
between nations I think some of the
issues also not just about how we
recover about spending also how we are
to live our lives we have to have a
fundamental rethink it's not sustainable
and the leaders said this morning we are
all in this together yeah I think those
are the issues so it's or all the
answers questions that have been put to
us it doesn't resolve us today is it
depends we actually have to change the
way we think about each other the way to
relate to each other and then try to
solve the problems I think we're still
putting some old paradigms maybe the
crisis needs to deepen you both we have
that arnhem but I think there's enough
people moving in that direction and like
I'm positive about that and I think we
have a circle would be to solving a
problem we'll be talking about not
getting karma change there we are okay